[Music]
paul is with us paul is in springfield
massachusetts hi paul welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave hi ken
hey what's up
quick question for you i'm on my
church's finance committee and we're
going to be having a capital campaign
fundraiser coming up
for a new social center
and
in massachusetts the marijuana industry
is now legal and so i i've been thinking
about
um what what is your
thoughts on
receiving donations or soliciting
donations from
someone who you know makes their living
from that industry and is it something
that we should consider or not consider
i know you always say money is neither
moral or immoral and even though i'm
against it should i not care about it or
should i care about it
well who are you are you talking about
just walking out in the community and
knocking on doors or these people in
your church
there are people are in the church
they're in the church okay so you have a
guy that sells pot legally that goes to
your church
right does he tithe or give
i do not know that
okay what is your
uh
spiritual your church's spiritual stand
on this in the community
um i think we're against it
um
you know but then i sort of say well if
it was a liquor store
which you know not a big drinker at all
but uh you know i don't think we have
any problem with that so then i'm like
is it just am i trying to be
overthinking it or not overthinking it
well i
uh both are certainly legal in your
state
okay the question is how you all
perceive it
as a as a church okay from a spiritual
viewpoint um if you are if your pastor
stands up in the pulpit and preaches
against drinking under any circumstances
then even though a liquor store is legal
you shouldn't take money from them that
would be hypocritical
agreed right
and if he stands up in the pulpit and
says even though marijuana is now legal
we don't think it's good we think that
you know smoking pot getting high is a
sin i don't think you ought to do that
then you know taking
uh
money from the local weed store is
hypocritical
right
yeah that's what i do now if you're but
if your pastor is ambivalent about it
and your pastor and the spiritual
leaders the uh the deacons the elders
however your church is governed and
structured from a spiritual standpoint
if they're ambivalent about it and they
they they put you know pot in the same
category as liquor
then
you know and and you're not you don't
you don't have an issue from a spiritual
standpoint if we wouldn't call it sin
okay then then
you know
uh uh for instance the church that i go
to
uh alcohol is not something that is
preached against
obviously in moderation but having a
glass of wine or a glass of bourbon or
something like that
our pastor does not scream and yell and
get read in the face about it okay and
so that church receiving tithes from the
local liquor store would not be a
problem uh
you know at the church that i attend as
an example okay but if you went to a
church that had that stance there to
receive the money is hypocritical
so i think you need to establish where
you all stand on this issue and then
that will tell you
spiritually where you stand and that
will tell you whether to take the money
or not
make sense
yes it does and as a member of the
finance committee you've got to talk to
church leadership about this get their
position on it as dave's laid it out
i'll give you another example okay i'll
give you another example most
evangelical churches would be strongly
pro-life anti-abortion
and to take tithe money
or capital campaign money from an
abortion doctor that attends that church
would be uh would be hypocritical as
crud
right
is it you know it's the money is not
dirty
but the person that you're you're
allowing them to attend the church
because you hope you can change them you
hope you can lead them to a better way
of life
a better way of living a better a better
set of activities if you believe that
what they're doing is wrong okay and so
you've gotta but you know and i'm
assuming
let's just make a you know let's just
make an example here further at your
church if your church says hey
we don't believe smoking pot is okay
from a spiritual standpoint we don't
believe that if they take that stand
then they not only should not accept
this money but they also should begin to
walk with their arm around this weed
store owner and lead him into your way
of thinking or
make him uncomfortable enough that he
finds a church where it's okay to own a
wheat store
you know and that because it needs to be
consistent in a spiritual walk and we
need to be clear about what's
what is sin what isn't in your in the
way you all take a stand on staff but
the money itself is not dirty
it's how we're treating the people
kindly and kindly disagree with them
if we need to